what's with the jeans what is going on
guys how are we doing this now yeah we
rolling welcome to your mom's house
podcast i am christina pazsitzky
Tom Segura my husband is is it
Minneapolis this week so standing in for
him is the godless sodomite Ari Shaffir
backup backup husband backup husband and
resident Jew hi everyone thought of me
once and mr. red ban hey I don't know
why they call you red ban does everybody
know that except me I used to be a
projectionist for like ten years and
then the internet first came out I and
everyone was like getting screen names
and stuff and I just picked red band
from red band trailers like movie
trailers used to be like red banner
green band and I was gonna just do red
band but then I was thinking then people
think I'm in a band so took out the D
and just called myself a red man red
band that's cool yeah cuz red man's
already taken right by a black guy it
also sounds like your band who raps man
Yeah right Method Man is a bunch of
man's how are you guys doing this week
I'm doing also happening I'm doing
awesome really I have an ear infection
oh it's tasty it's from a cold of last
week and this is like the second one
I've had in six months and I haven't had
them since I was like 10 years old and
it make you fall doesn't make me it
makes me not want to eat anything or do
anything makes you dizzy at all no no I
tell you though oh I do have a great
piece of advice for people that don't
have health insurance yeah I'm almost
there um if you if you go to a place is
called the MinuteClinic uh-huh it's at
the CVS pharmacy there's a few of them
in LA and it only costs like 60 bucks
and a nurse practitioner sees you yeah
that's always easier right it's such a
river you call the doctor they're like
yeah you can come in you know two weeks
from now and you're like well I'll be
deaf by then so I just go just like for
precision so you can just get a
prescription immediately and it costs
like 60 bucks 60 bucks and then
you know obviously don't go there if
you've been hit by a car and you're
bleeding but like if you have an ear
infection or a cold or cough or
something it's like the best thing ever
a couple years ago I just forgot to pay
my premiums for insurance so I called
was like ed you didn't make an
appointment
I mean infection and they were like oh
you don't have insurance so I have to go
to the free clinic for a staph infection
but it took too long but it was like
totally free really you don't pay
anything the doctor visit and then they
give you this card so you know have
insurance and then you don't pay
anything for the antibiotics where is
this a free clinic like downtown there's
a few around town it's a dicey though is
I mean will I get raised your whiz I'm
writing no I mean not wearing that you
get the prescription drugs from a guy in
a car the one on Santa Monica Vermont
maybe not but yeah I was totally fine
it's the wait way longer
yeah that's the only part but the minute
clinics like 15 minutes is there like a
limit to what the Minute Clinic can do
like I mean you're not gonna go in there
and like I got these things on my dick
right it is more like I have a cold and
I want some yeah its basic stuff like
you know what's wrong with you and you
just need it's like it's just like I
need penicillin can I have some fuck you
might have something like why do I have
to go make an appointment and sit in a
waiting room to get some fucking
antibiotics and like in the Arab world
you can just walk into these places and
get you know they have pharmacist yeah
yeah you just go and buy everything and
it's okay whatever you want yeah it's
just it's so stupid like who's gonna
overdose on penicillin why must we
regulate these they're in a song are you
yes so what do you take when you have
there's all these fake kind of
penicillins I guess like I don't know
maca Sicilian I think Moxie ceilings
actually the same I don't remember they
don't work like quite as well yeah they
don't work quite as well so I'm always
like getting this bullshit help you know
like I'm fucking dying you know like
well here's this thing that will kind of
help you and I remember I took
penicillin once when I was a kid I just
broke out with these hives everywhere
and sometimes I've been so sick I'm like
I'll take hives over when I'm
now you know that's so terrible that's
like a fundamental drug to be allergic
yeah
penicillin talks fascinating fucking
miss prime Optimus Prime lives next door
and he's always fucking cleaning up and
shit are you guys allergic to anything
at all well to rail on or whatever that
fake bull is what happens I just get
sniffles and my eyes water up on cats
yeah I think cats for me to really is
there a cat there's a cat although my
cat allergies gone way down in the last
few years
yeah I kind of tolerate it too because I
like petting them so much it's like oh
I'll take them there's also cats that
your totally can be allergic to and
other cats that you would not be
allergic to it's all based on their
dander dander when I was a girl with a
cat in hers it wasn't that bad yeah but
with Diaz a 10 I'll treat cats Joey Diaz
has now 11 cats 11 and I haven't been
inside of his house yet but I've been to
the point where you're at your front
door and you go look inside of his house
cuz I never thought it was true I was
like alright he doesn't really have 11
cats he's probably got it like five and
there's like all these cats that live
outside no just dude the one peek inside
that I got it was just like cats
everywhere a cat on TV another cat
chasing another cat just it looked like
a madhouse and I know I have like
attacks I have like heart attacks just
from having these - yeah it's like that
Russian video of you seeing like five
hundred cats that woman's apartment it
smell terrible
I don't smell your cats but generally if
you have a lot that you can just smell
it I use a lot of like candles and all
the bullshit things you know what the
best episode of Hoarders ever was is
when they found 35 dead cats and this
woman's house lying around 35 yeah it
always at 35 cats total and some of them
were dead like car-like skeletons and
she's like what
I didn't know Wow no one says show that
seems wonderful even on Netflix I'm such
a hoarder too but not are you really
like microwaves stacked on microwaves in
his living room
Underwood's I don't work anymore I'm
like I got this out so put it by the
door and I'll leave it there for a year
and a half and what way what's what
compels you to not throw it away are you
I gotta get to that I think laziness
more than like I need I might need that
again there's some of that where it's
like some things I don't throw out
because like who knows when this will
come back in a style or yeah so there
that that fear of the utility of it like
oh I might need a microwave it doesn't
work I don't have it I was not a first
sketch maybe all that's what I always I
never did like it's been like seven
years so like are you one of those gross
boys that the house is filthy do you
have a mattress on the floor no my
husband was like that when I met some
mattress on the floor no soap in the
shower I don't have soap I don't do so
good you know you can tell a man is
filthy is when he smells like bananas
and jizz like it's a special combination
bananas I don't know this but the
bananas is like remember like in college
and you saw bananas in my trash cans my
bathroom and now you're saying that I
smell like bananas and jizz no but like
I remember like Jim at full Tron and he
he and like a bunch of boys live
together at one point in Silverlake and
I'd hang out at their house and boy
houses when you get a group of them
together it's just it's just hair
everywhere and just just jizz and
bananas Metin dirty dishes oh this is
yes but that's not my kitchen if
something's not good do you live alone I
live alone but mostly I'm not dirty
as much as I'm cluttered like I won't we
pizza boxes out the bones I'll throw out
immediately
roaches that's why I add them you know
how mad is the worst I meant I'm not
necessarily a dirty person
I just I just got so much animals and
I've noticed ever since I've ripped the
carpet offer out here that that just
collects balls of these missed they're
not cat hair they're just like hair hair
yeah we're not even that but they just
seem like dust
bunnies I guess or you have hardwood
floors now - yeah I've never had
hardwood floors now have dolls of like
look like kittens everywhere you gotta
sleep like every few days you're pretty
clean watch out for the dog is ruining
but the most beautiful and like she
needs something though she's doing
something re get the gum out of her
mouth for God's sake what is that this
is a nice house though red band you keep
it clean for a boy I will say yeah he's
also had girls here in the recent past
oh so that that's what get worse and
worse right right I would peg by nature
I know if I hate cleaning I hate it Oh
Claire's your place then well now I Tom
and I both do but the place we live
before in downtown was just it was total
hoarders like it was not by the way you
can get like an awesome cleaning person
in the LA area $40.00 everyone they
steal from them know every single person
I know that has one has said the same
why do we and it's like I can't find my
thing it must be stolen my new Chuck
Taylors and you look six months later
like oh they're under my bed with all
the rest of my shoes we don't have a
good shit to steal we're comics we have
no one ever goes and says oh I assumed
she stole for me and she didn't I was
wrong about telling everyone that my
mates told well you know who I'm talking
about nari and that's that that was a
legit she actually admitted to it Oh a
maid or a woman I made oh yes you gotta
make God and they've been in like a long
time person but whatever we don't need
to go into that but no no I mean that's
what I'm afraid of because like I get
freaked out if somebody comes over to my
house I don't know I don't just go oh
hey hey I'll see you later
Mikey's awesome if you want you sit here
yeah unless I have no pants on that does
not seem fun yeah I'm a wolf you mop the
floor for next two hours you know I tell
me was masturbating one time in his
house and the cleaning lady came in this
is before I lived yeah I mean she fully
caught him I wish she was here to tell
that
in the in the hotel no in a house and
silver like that he lived in before we
moved in together great I can't wait to
walk in on him masturbating one day you
know and I keep waiting for my call one
day it's gonna be so great when I laugh
so hard
have you tried you gotta like
supermarket for a while then wait like
three or four minutes then come back
slowly
my favorite thing is always when you did
the girl and she's like you know you
have sex and she doesn't come but you're
like she says I really want to come and
like oh hey you know you can masturbate
oh I'm just gonna go to the bathroom and
go get some you know go in the kitchen
okay okay and then like she keep the
door a little open and then you sneak
move it never happens to me
you always come no I'm not an animal
like that for sure what are you doing
you just mess with mine is it yours
yeah why didn't I go down yeah yeah
that's the main volume each individual
item is volume is next to each plug
you're doing the main volume for both of
them close dude Oh Howard Stern just
renewed his contract he did finally talk
like he's gonna do a podcast you know he
always does this every time his
contracts are up he meows and meows oh
wow and then of course I stopped
listening at him he's just he's an old
man yeah it's like an old Jewish woman
that's what he reminds me of well I grew
up listening to him I've been listening
since I was 14 and you know my friends
like that I just think he's so funny and
so great but maybe it is time I just
never got into it there's never was them
in the morning never and then I mean
here they air like once or twice but it
was always like I didn't like when he
how to argue it to people and then hung
up on them and they continue the
argument I'm like of course they're
losing they are
because they're not there to like retort
everything you're saying yeah so you
never got addicted to him ever even when
you I admit that I used to be a huge
fucking fan but then it lately it's just
like an Aggie old lady just coming
listen to Greece man he was just a kid
of God you know Greece Manila he got
banned for like a year once were thrown
off for a year for saying on Martin
Luther King Day kill for more look at
the whole week off but now you could
never say that that was like 20 years
ago
yeah it's not interesting I was noticing
we become so much more uptight like even
the movies we grew up on like like
Ghostbusters or fucking vacation or what
about Blazing Saddles like you watch
that movie now and it's still like oh my
god do they say nigger and you're like
it's really it's so much more subversive
and and funny
yeah they make today yeah it is it's
like go for it there's you know there's
like the stereotypes come from somewhere
you can even at least make fun of them
or we're not all the same yeah I agree
and I don't know what's wrong with
admitting to that and there's a better
or worse right just different that's
right I agree yeah could you get in
trouble just by saying well some people
are yeah I know some people aren't yeah
not only that is generational to like my
parents are kind of old-school and
racist and like what's that and you know
Thanksgiving my dad has opinions about
black people that are just on
Thanksgiving only Thanksgiving my
friends are over and he can monologue
but like what's the you know what am I
gonna do what am I gonna do tell him to
change his opinion he's 64 years old
that's who he is and then something you
realized to this we're talking about how
like kids like like college kids think
they know everything
yeah yeah well you realize like I'll be
60 at some point too and I'll have some
you know implicated ideas about things
but like just it's okay man the good
dad's not an idiot he was privy to all
the information that you were that's
right
he's decided that's his way the best
thing about hanging out with
people though is like like my mom him I
shouldn't say my mom's fuck
but anyway it's like relatives older
relatives is like they they will get mad
at you if you say something gross or
you'll cause like you'll be huh
but then if I just for fun we'll throw
out man this fucking Bingbing today at
the quarry store she's like wow what do
you do what do you do Indian people are
very argumentative by nature like idea
what this one he always arguing it's
like Native American let me tell you my
stepfather's Indian and I had three
Indian stepsisters growing up and they
are argument yeah and they steal and my
stepdad was a criminal and he would cut
people's tires the hardest thing I've
had to deal with personally nice snort
yeah as you get older realizing that
some racial stereotypes are perceived
like you've decided that on your own and
they're not wrong what do you watch the
waitresses and they like black people
don't those are not racist people to
begin with they've learned that behavior
from black people continuously not
tipping that mean ly nari I will agree
with you because I was a waitress for
many years and black people often don't
give the best tips and it's not a honey
you might get a break but generally
they've made it as an observation and
it's across the board in America they're
like black people don't do it that's
true so it's like is that racist adjust
experience with somebody I agree I don't
know why we have to make concessions for
having opinions about groups about
people a big fucking deal maybe it is
true the black people don't tip does it
make them bad no why people are extreme
you can say good stereotypes that's sort
of okay to say Jews or Asians are smart
successful but nobody's like that how
can you say that that's not true for
everyone that's true what does Italy CK
has that bit where he's like I'm a white
male
you can't even hurt my feelings like
there's there's not even a a slur that
can hurt white people's feelings
yeah but white people aren't shitty I
will say that as far as crowds go as a
comedian white people are on the release
favorite the other born they're boring
as shit they're uptight they have white
guilt about everything
and also there's a denial about the
truth white people oh I'm so effect
where people love to be offended by
people's perhaps oh yeah yeah so
offensive offensive to who yeah and
fucking grow up like you know really
kills me as when people talk about clean
comedians versus dirty all the dirty
what do you mean like to me there's two
types of people people who live in
reality and deal with dirty things that
make them feel icky yeah and then people
who fucking don't I talked to that fan
once who makes his living as a clean
family comedian oh we were talking about
whatever he's a nice guy though but I
was personally just clean community oh
yeah asshole puckering every time I
would you don't ever want to like talk
about wanting to fuck your wife or that
goes oh I do want to talk about it but I
can't
why because I I'll lose my income oh
he's stricted by that and he won't be
able to fully express who he is
that's interesting it seems kind of like
a lame existence you know there is
definitely there's definitely comics
though that take the clean comedy to the
right - right like John Heffron he's not
it
I guess completely clean comic but his
clean comedies actually I can deal with
you know and Brian Regan but you don't
really know him right can I tell you
honestly I got a problem I know buddy
nice library it's not anybody personal
but I have never listened to like a
squeaky clean comic and been like yeah
man that's funny
or like I get that it never gets me in a
visceral sort of like fuck yeah like
it's not the same as listening to
Richard Pryor talk about having a heart
attack
yeah doing too many drugs and like wow
where's the truth Brian Regan I don't
know him as a person I'm sure he's a
fine guy but I'm sure he's got dark shit
looming like we all do like all the
great about that all the greatest
literature you've read over the years is
all a bit about some fucked up
experience yeah precious or whatever it
is MoMA it's not like there's no great
books about what was a few but it's not
many about I was just up in middle class
and nothing really happened to it well
and I always think to like I I feel like
I can assess a man by his act like you
show me the act and I'll tell you what's
going on in that dudes head and to me
it's fucking weird when a guy doesn't
talk about jerking off and doesn't talk
about
whatever hateful shit inside of him and
you know that guy is a time bomb you
know what I mean like it I just I feel
like the guys are talking about Wario's
and shit like those guys are gonna
murder that guy's gonna there are me and
David Taylor talk about us that are for
the people who like teen comedy I don't
like the economy there are some really
horrible dirty comics a bad dirty comic
hit it makes me feel bad for the 30 I'm
like you're just going for shock
absolutely yes it's like his latest act
and ever since he found Jesus he has he
found Jesus know me to do anything yes
he was at flappers last weekend well
yeah funny I mean funny and they say
that funny is funny and if it's dirty
and just not funny that's that's
terribly enjoy your there and if you
only do in five minutes like okay you
can cool this you clean joke but it's
like I know over a lifespan of
somebody's act yeah nothing well I just
get sick and tired of that like I was in
Arizona and I had this this fat female
comic come up to me afterwards and was
like you're very funny and she goes you
know I'm an anomaly I'm a clean female
comic and I was like oh fuck off like
don't you know kiss my are you funny
though you know it's one thing just I
don't know are you pretty dirty on stage
I see that the thing is that I am I I
don't know but I just talk about what
the truth is to me and if that includes
talking about shitting great that's what
it's gonna be that day and if it
includes talking about but sex or
whatever that's reality it's not it's
not clean or dirty it's reality
yeah so I don't do anything
intentionally vulgar I like to sit where
people like oh you're dirty comment oh I
guess so I guess based on what you're
saying but I'm not trying to be dirty
ever sometimes I talk about thirty stuff
sometimes but I'm not going for it it's
just like I'm talking about whatever I
talk about I don't really consider it
yeah you don't think in terms like if
you I can't her sorry is this bit
whatever like I don't know it's just
something about the water people are
like don't curse and the whole time
you're like
yeah anyways I do that laughs activate a
couple things before they're all night
long okay mr. kids in hospitals oh I
actually try did not curse I just choose
bits that were a little cleaner it was
like have you ever kissed in the shower
or what but I hate if you like you're
dirty like I yes yeah yeah you're pretty
fucking dirty man I mean my defensive
dirty I don't think yeah it is what are
you talking you just don't know what it
is what are you talking about right now
I'm talking about how we're all judging
people for doing the same stuff that we
do and how hypocritical it is for each
but there's three stuff in there I talk
about shitting inside there yeah what's
part of life man yeah you know talk
about shitting all right you're a pretty
dirty person in general though you're
they're one of the few people that I
know that I talked to an immediate
you're like hey let's go on FaceTime and
he's showing it and hit me as dick or
he'll send me a video of him taking a
shower and just pull out his dick in the
bathtub I'm not offended by this stuff
looks like it's funny it's particularly
dudes dude did you often show their
genitals to each other never never
showed my dick to another guy ever your
beanbag
not even your channel not even my
beanbag all the time even shown a nipple
to something I just I'm also the guy in
the locker room that just put a towel
into a stall you know I
a modest is that I just don't feel the
need to show my addictive evil I don't
know I I guess I grew up better than you
fucking savithri oh I want to it's again
there's so many flaccid Dixit in there
there was hilarious though where you
turned off by that way no I think that's
okay but like if I'm sitting in a room
with you and you show me your dick I'm
just like alright woah but that's
unnecessary you could have drawn that
for me and I did all of it necessary
yeah a lot of people do that's where
they create a lineup like that's I want
this and no more and then that's all
they I think is acceptable day I think
only comics do that though I've been
there maybe that's it maybe just it's a
comic thing because I don't hang out any
of my friends they're the same way they
don't
they're dicks to anybody yeah I know my
husband does like he said dick pictures
and there's always assholes and dicks
being texted around or whatever I mean I
think it's funny I love this makes me
laugh me too
so what's the mush pile well girls need
to start showing their pussies then
maybe I'll join for some reason you got
to make it funny
you're not trying fucking get caught
your pussy boner and just got a pussy
bone yeah you know like the part that
girl vaginas are an external that's a
problem yeah the flippity floppity Ness
it's the motion of the penis and the
testicles and it looks so much different
when they're ready for sex and when
they're not yeah I want to ask you Ari I
know you want to see a pink floyd-- yeah
Joey Diaz we took some acid Joey called
me he's like we're going to see Pink
Floyd I call your mushroom guy acid
first of all I didn't think he could do
acid past the age of 30 at least I made
a vow to myself never did because of
life responsibility when did you make
that vow to yourself when I was like 23
the last time I did ask when you're
making assumptions about what you'd be
like when you're 30 right and lame yeah
I had a theory that you can't get a
tattoo past 30 ha ha did you give a
tattoo mm-hmm what do you have it's the
best tattoo ever actually just found out
reasonably soil tracking keep on truckin
I thought that was fake I thought that's
one of those stickers like he wouldn't
get that as a real tab I'm surprised
like that's very good I thought it was
fake for like a year and I care to
convince you then I licked it and do
whatever you want
write whatever you want but I'm saying
that the neat first of all do you know
that kids don't even do acid anymore
it's not hip like I asked a book and I
asked some college because I know you
guys do acid and they're like what
what's acid like it it doesn't
apparently bunch of other shit
oxy I don't fucking know Molly ecstasy
xs-extra in a big oven Molly oh that's
it I know Molly is I know okay
ain't never you a Grateful Dead head
were you a hippie back in the day now
dude I was an angry punk or change
I started everything else when I was 13
years old I was smoking weed I was in
Hollywood I was I had a mohawk
I was very angry and I liked punk rock
and then oh my god
like opposite of hardcore dad's no doubt
like a black-eyed peas a radical no but
I remember the first time I took acid I
was 15 or 14 years old it was a loser
and I was goth and I had on like a
velvet dress and I was wearing retainers
like that's how young I was
and an acid came on and I fucking lost
my mind because I took two tabs for my
first time who tabs rephrase what's
wrong with you I think it's having a
half it didn't really work that well
really you know well you take the first
half and then nothing happens and you go
just take another one and that's how you
get screwed then you shouldn't do that
but I remember I was watching Siouxsie
and the Banshees aids came on and then
the acid hit and I lost my mind
what'd you do well I was with my sister
and our friends are a little weird goth
or not yeah we also get together and I
just lost we all lost our minds like
there's you I can't go to move out yeah
that's why the problem that yeah it's
like people are gonna know yeah
and it's a first time I did it she knew
so I was like what the fuck nice to me
people they all know they all know or
you're gonna ruin their day by screaming
or something and being that guy around
them that's unfroze what are you
supposed to do I know friends drive on
mushrooms oh my god concentrate on one
thing that's a constant like the radio
thing I know that's real like you should
be driving when you have to convince
yourself that something's real no way
wait so you did it this time and have
you done it before never denounced it
before this is your virgin voyage yeah
if you will it's emotional mushroom guys
like I'm in but I'm two months away I'm
right in the middle of a grow so I had
nothing so deals like I'm getting some
acid then we're going to think for I
couldn't think of a better guy who acid
with the first time yeah he's so good I
don't actually I don't think I would I
don't think I would want ideas you know
what's going on and be cool with like
calming you down when you need to
because he's been through it like a
thousand times
as long as you tell them it's your first
time and so were you nervous at all a
little bit we did a half at at first was
like let's to have the done for and the
Kosmos is at a time for it was just half
get your skin pops he said get your skin
pops yeah I don't know I think it's like
taking like half a hit of weed and then
waiting time manages yes well that's
just that's what I learned with acid is
that you gotta wait a little bit of time
give it give it 30 to 40 minutes to kick
in yeah get weird let it get weird let
it ride yeah well we did so we took it a
for 403 and then at like 5:30 on the
subway were like I got nothing wait wait
the subway no where are you you know a
we weren't from North Hollywood were
going downtown at Staples and we figure
we take the subway able Center on ass
see I don't get that because when I did
acid I'm like Carrie I got couch I got
weed I got a backyard I got you know
some beyond the mind's eye CDs or DVDs I
got some good music and candles and a
lava lamp
that's all I don't the last thing I want
to do is go to a fucking staples like a
nightmare before joints my pocket you're
also he's also the same guy that decided
to eat mushrooms and go see a movie I
wanna see a movie I wonder what that
movie about mushrooms and how was that
experience movie theater empty it was
okay and I didn't trip too hard I have
actually watched yellow submarine
while on acid yeah and it's the most
horrifying terrifying experience I've
ever had and I had to turn it off
immediately really you don't need drugs
to watch that no it's about drugs it's
about yeah it doubled up it was too much
I also couldn't tell how someone it's
like the vines and assigned stuff for
the fuck were all like moving and weird
like if I was Tim Burton was doing that
or outside you just went to a forest
instead you know that's the best being
in nature or force I'm going to next
time we're gonna take some and go to the
condo in La Jolla at the Comedy Store
and just have a bunch of guys and have
the beach right there okay I need how it
is how is the genesis of this it's I
want to see Pink Floyd Joey Diaz
I'm like you know what that seems like a
good time to do at the wall he's just
doing the wall from start to finish
did it really that I used to listen that
so much as a teenager the first tape I
bought yeah 1899 what the fuck but I was
too insecure back then to say oh that I
don't want it I couldn't like take a
stand like that so I'd like okay I guess
all my money's gone
but do you remember the movie I mean I
would watch that movie the last time
they did the concert
then they did the wall overall yeah I
think yeah why and I saw that on
mushrooms I wasn't with my first time
doing mushrooms I believe I how long boy
the wall maybe 90 there's these pigs
that was a that was no no I saw it
93 yeah something wasn't the last time
oh that yeah but yeah that was weird
so you were on the subway going towards
so Diaz shows me in his mouth he's like
take some tinfoil he's like whatever am
I gonna do it he wants to make sure I
see so I keep like they got the clock
alright another one another full one the
whole thing because I couldn't air it
sorry see it you did
okay and then I did a full one okay
so I wait a little while I try to tear
mine on the subway I could tear it so
it's a tab like school paper
yeah paper oh my god that's so old
school water well he said he got it off
for jail but he had to get like six
counties were things like 600 bucks like
what am I gonna do with this do it all
so I don't want this much around yeah
black pyramids with the little gold
speck on that's crazy I'm getting I'm
sweating and getting excited just
thinking about like because your body
you've never done acid it bodies away
yeah do you know that your brain waves
going to schizophrenia and you're just
sweating and you've got strychnine
coursing up and down yeah I heard what I
heard the strychnine somebody said that
that's all a urban legend I remember I
think when you I'm gonna get a car
accident in my back plate but then
what's not feeling that up and down your
spinal cord I don't know
see I personally think it's something
speed it's just bad
somebody says your time yeah yeah so
anyway okay you get all over body huh
first table I was immediately before I
even smoke pot within like 15 minutes
like oh I'm feeling something here so
yeah you feel like come on you're like
it's sorta like a little bit like get up
and go crazy and like feel this thing in
my body it feels nice but then that sort
of stayed no longer no harder than that
and so then I did another half a tab on
the subway and then as we got off was
like fuck it it's been another 20
minutes I don't have much you know
there's no visual so like I'll take the
other one suppose it to have in half and
then we got there like 6 o'clock like at
the Staples Center and they had like
three tickets left at a super corner
where you couldn't really see much like
a let's wait for scalpers and it still
was just not kicking in crazy yeah so
we're like just called it like we
couldn't get any good seats it was no
good seats to buy and all we heard is
don't sit up too close because the wall
is humongous and you can't see anything
and don't sit in the corner and that's
all we could find so we're like why are
we spending 200 bucks
we're on acid it doesn't kick in and
it's like what we're gonna watch the
wall and shitty seats over let's fuck it
let's just forget it yeah to me that's
like I could buy a blu-ray player and
the wall on laserdisc less than that I
don't mind going to see you crazy event
I have a hundred bucks here they're like
what's wrong while I could spend a
hundred billion dollars on something but
we walked away I went to the pantry and
then it kicked in oh okay and that was
bad being downtown the chair dear the
chair got really far away like this is
bad I can't look at my arm it was like
whoa then I'm like what's the plan now
cuz the concert started 30 minutes ago
we're in downtown LA and DEA's like
we're not going anywhere because he was
feeling it too okay good
and then the guy he ate or me or
whatever it was it wasn't hungry no you
can't eat no I just never did something
yeah every time you eat you just start
looking and start melting or so yeah and
then they brother check over and look we
gotta leave and he's like oh we get some
coffee
okay 18 hours can we sit here yeah they
wrote the new check and then like 10
minutes later do you like dessert maybe
cuz anything that we could stay there
you didn't think maybe just like God I
don't know find like a park or heroine
parks who lives there near they're
terrible it's it becomes after sundown
downtown LA is a ghost town with zombies
zombies that come out of MacArthur Park
or the igloo homeless people like it's
it's real dicey yeah I mean we used to
see people just shitting on the streets
I'm just paying with my pay to live here
you should be free so so what did you do
so you just a little bit let me walk
this that way went home they tried to
call me and they're like we're coming
over
that's not wasted it was like a good
feeling without a crazy what the visuals
weren't amazing we di said it was weak
assets we need to do like two tabs why
why wait so long in life to try to try
drugs before no no no yeah and a half
something I want to present to you guys
good idea but because I grew up in an
Orthodox Jewish I went to school with
Orthodox Jews oh my god the only the
only like beer we have it like one party
once and Manischewitz wine yeah but it
was like nobody drank and we did
anything some bad kids at Dunn beer now
your parents are both Orthodox yeah are
you an only child no for kids the only
drugs we had were people that came to
speak to our school as part of like
right dere right program was a fucking
only taught me which I was gonna do yeah
it was like what's mescaline do all
right
it's like Alyssa thanks for the map
Nancy Reagan now I know exactly what our
quaaludes I was so bummed by the time I
I got the high school they didn't make
him anymore I know in fact thing cuz
you're like what squalene I have to go
to the library you know the card catalog
system you're pulling out books
I wish I could Oh to this day I wish wow
I'm sorry okay well I heard people
saying I messed up my life at cocaine
like it was just it's a little ruin your
labor bills you lose your wife in your
house and even to this day I still have
a little bit like but then I'm like you
see never done cooking I've done it a
few times but very little but all my
friends do cocaine and they're fine
they're not losing their homes they're
just funny yeah right like it's okay
well I can actually make a career look
at Ballou she was phenomenal no cocaine
a lot of artists are actually a lot
better but now you have adderall that's
just the same but a lot of great music
and great artists it's been created on
drugs that's the pot which my mom thinks
of as drugs so it's like maybe people
are just wrong they just judge say force
if they haven't done well you know
what's interesting they say pot is the
gateway drug
I disagree alcohol well yeah like what's
the next thing so I wanna say there's no
pot those people are just gonna go
straight to us I smoked weed when I was
13 and then by 14 I was doing acid so
wait so okay so you're raising this
ultra conservative household your Todd
the drugs are the devil's but you just
don't do them there's better and what
about like sexuality and yes never
genitals 23 and were you able to did you
mastery yeah yo yeah I masturbated
before I could even come well I've heard
that I didn't know what it was what I
was doing right never feel no you'd feel
the organs would happen but nothing
would come out like your body wasn't
producing anything just didn't make any
mustard yeah I was fucking coming when I
was 12 you were rubbing him out before
anything I would inside my jeans they
were just bloody we're in in synagogue
er no no never a temple at some point I
knew well he's doing some planted that
yeah but I didn't quite know why how did
your parents address sexuality with you
I've never talked about it really so how
did you learn uh TV and friends other
teenage boys excellent see a movie but
the only problem is getting it for
movies you like am I supposed to last
like an hour and a half every time it's
been a train
and girls like no yes play you're
watching a sex play when you're watching
pornography it's not real no there's
cuts in like a movie version like in
what was that Mel Gibson movie
wait he's a loose cannon leave the
weapon yeah it's someone who's like I
don't know and it seemed like it was
like clinical have you had that like I
hate my thing is and this is kind of a
but the kind of the same line is when
girls are like you need to stop start
making noises in bed because I I'm a
real quietly mmm-hmm kind of guy I love
him guilty loud but I like when girls
get loud you know I'm now loud I don't
know why it's mostly cuz I've been I was
hiding you know from or something I
don't know in my mom's house you're
supposed to that's how you learn to be a
grown-up don't lie so people are like
you know you have to be loud in beds and
then I try and it's just the most
embarrassing thing I'm like and I'm like
this is so stupid but I guess they like
this better and then the same person
this is like an ex-girlfriend from a
while ago they're like uh they're like
you need to be more like aggressive you
need to take control and so you know
I've heard this remember Daisy Gardner
she's a comedian but she used to give
advice this girl but she was like more
gothic her friend who gave and she's got
a smile more I was getting more more
respected people a nice smile more but
it's like no you get more respect new
smile more and the girls want the type
of guy who gets into sex more but they
don't that's not you that's never gonna
be you so you're just faking it well
that's what I'm like so I think I should
like start like pinching myself or
something when I have sex or just like
like put my like credit score on the on
the pillow next to me and just look out
and get pissed or
I think the worst thing that the impor
knows are the girls always do is they
just pretty much when they're dirty
they're just telling you what you're
already doing right like yeah fuck that
pussy yeah yeah slap that but it's like
I'm doing like I was just doing you know
I really dislike into pornography is
when the girl gets blasted on her face
and then it's not enough that it's on
her face she has to scoop it into oh man
I got wasted but is that a thing for men
but they have to know that their semen
is not being it's all of its gonna go in
like a something forgotten hey I came
mom's last on a girl's face because I
went to professor's really the meaning
to me oh yeah I don't get it and I don't
like I don't like the spitting I can't
handle why the spinning on everybody's
genitals in these movies what happened
it's just good old-fashioned like yeah
it's like I don't need to huncle your
pussy I'm choking I don't like choking I
never knew that so I found a girl in San
Diego it was your it became your thing
yeah but now some girls who aren't into
joking are into at least me wait I'm
sorry not choking link I'm gonna choke
you but girls a gag I'm sorry and it's
killing her put it down as far as you
want but be comfortable yeah I've never
taken a girl's head and pushed it down
yeah never had a girl suck my balls
either salad potassium or agile no know
how that to and I was like I don't know
why you're doing it's like I'm not into
it
doesn't make me feel good or bad yes I
could just do a girl but I can't do it I
don't want it don't you don't want to do
it were gone - guys asses are hairy and
I would not want a girl to do that just
okay so what do you think of this idea
because you would I got a ghost and I
got to go to doctor but I want to do so
they never did I want to do every drug
bun - any needles no everything
and either write about it or do a
podcast about it but it's like from no
experience just everything it seems like
a very bad idea
just try and just like one time I'm
gonna do coke and then one time crack
and then maybe one time coke and go out
with it one time stay at home see what
the differences are well I think that's
a surefire way of cultivating a drug
habit yeah like one time and then you
know that's one time like you're gonna
do heroin and be like that was the most
beautiful thing I've accidentally smoked
heroin once really when I was a teenager
and what and nothing like you just get
super loaded and then you're like what
was that all about and I never did it
again you know I mean I think that like
in in my life I have done almost one of
every talk over the span of like a few
of years no experience it's so easy to
say oh look at you you're doing this but
it's like I don't know what that's like
but I think also I was in a bad state of
mind when I was doing those things right
very angry and very troubled and I think
kind of you know I don't recommend it
while you're an adult because that's I
don't know that just does not seem like
a good idea that seems like something
that if you do it young enough and if
you fuck up at a young age you have
enough time to recover and get your life
back but I know people like squares but
you know squares people normal of people
back home that think that I'm wasting my
life if you smoke pot every day or if
you smoke pot once a week they like get
a life and it's like no you just don't
get us doing nothing bad to me it's just
fun
I smoke pot but you smoke pot all day so
you're doing the same thing you're
saying because it's not what you want to
do no no no I'm saying it gets to a
point where you're fucking smoking it
all day long and it feels like you're
relying on it to live so you're saying
it will feel like that when you smoke
pot all day long huh you're saying it
feels like that to you well it's like
any kind of drug dude if you have if you
have alcohol you drink alcohol that all
day that's there's no say look you can
have a beer there's no reason to get
sloshed for no reason but you were like
no you don't get it I want to get drunk
yeah but you wake up smoke weed and
smoke weed all day to go to bed that's a
problem
no matter the waters I don't but why do
you think it would be if
because you're not even getting high you
you are you are reaching for doing
something thinking you're getting high
but you're just going and going and
going trying to get this is what I'm
talking about that's another that's
addiction
well like but I get do it but I get high
I get high on pot alright and guess what
I smoke a bowl right now and I'll be
fuckin blazed a million times more
stunning but yes you get more high than
I do but there's a people who never
smoked pot that will get higher than you
do right but there's no right or wrong
there's just your situation
no no but two hours from now I'm not
thinking I need to get that high again
and then two hours later I'm like I need
to get high again that's that's that's
interrupting your lifestyle because
you're fucking thinking that you have to
do that to survive that is the nature of
addiction is that you you function with
it yeah like heroin junkies they don't
even get high when they do heroin they
just need to take care of when to feel
normal
so if you need pot or whatever substance
just to feel normal
how about yeah well yeah then I'd say
that would be in it higher I just know
that when like two years ago before re
smoked weed or name it wasn't three
years ago four years ago he had barely
smoked weed and he took like one hit at
my house of let's bong and he almost got
in a car accident
that's right Ellis leave it a like back
then he was like I could only take one
hit a weed and that's all I want and
that's all I ever need cut to now we're
yeah but it's about all I needed then
and that's all I wanted that but that's
not there's that's no judgment on people
who do it more what I want is because
already started drugs late yeah this is
like this is your adolescence of drug
use like people say about women with me
like well I don't just want us one girl
that's just it's ridiculous you're 36
you should want a single woman oh no now
I'm like that is your decision
you're not calling but there's some
people are if I'm saying like the drug
use you're talking mentally
that's pretty normal I think to want to
do a lot of drugs but because you didn't
do it and you're adolescents are in
college like it's just like a latent
sort of weird yeah you can try it but
it'll fuck you up just so you know do it
now it's like don't go
that often I liked it it's just not
always for me but I do I do know that
doing every kind of drug it just fucks
with you like emotionally then you're
depressed after you do it that's what I
want to talk about you were right about
her just see what the effects are so I
actually know well I mean
go for it yeah I'm terrified I'd be as
scared I just remember when I first
started smoking weed I remember thinking
but even that next day I mean I got high
and I'm still hot enough right and I
remember thinking I am dumb today that
we has made me dumb I am not thinking at
my super ha no this is the next day
after getting stoned like this was like
shitty we from a bowl that I got in high
school I remember but I remember
thinking the next day and then I
remember thinking smoking weed and
having a beer or two and going wow that
combination fucking crazy
I can now I don't think about any of
that stuff like I've done it to the
point where I don't feel like I'm dumb
anymore when I smoke weed I'm just I'm
the same I'm just you know but that shit
adds up and I just don't realize it
anymore so when you're fucking smoking
weed all day you might think I'm fucking
thinking all these things I wouldn't
think if I was stoned and I'm so much
smarter when it's though and I feel like
I could more creative when I'm stoned
that might be the case but you also
forgetting that it's also taking it down
to like a dumber level useless why do
you smoke pot of all them knowing it
makes you dumber usually I don't I don't
I don't smoke weed like you shouldn't
smoke ever no no if I'm sitting in front
of my computer trying to think of new
ideas for editing a video I'll smoke
weed if I'm thinking up new jokes I'll
smoke weed if I'm hanging out with
friends and they they bring weed I'll
smoke it but I'm not sitting at home
ever by myself just smoking weed for no
reason at all oh that's probably
problematic I think it's problematic at
all I use it as a tool I don't use it
too right I don't use I have my brain
for that right but if you have been
thinking with your brain the whole your
whole life and you want a different
perspective of thing you throw some weed
in there and you're now you have a
different perspective that's why I use
it though that's why I use it for
editing anything creative that's what I
use it for but there's no reason to
fucking sit around and smoke weed when
you're just sitting here by yourself
doing nothing but people look at you but
you smell nice well if you're using it
to like chill out yeah I mean that's I'm
saying I think it has some so many
different uses
like for me I mean crazy anxiety I get
freaked out some days it's the only
thing I can do cannot fucking function
and I just have to get high and watch
80s movies right that's it right you
don't do it so stupid like it makes me
so retarded I can't I can't remember
what I have to do what do you well
that's a different kind of human later
wired that way
I can't drive on it I can't even talk to
people on it like I have to be alone or
just with one other person yeah I can't
I can't do anything on it I can't go
onstage when I'm drunk let's learn
terribly but some people can completely
they're fine with it
I can't even drink coffee before I go up
too high Zbornak yeah well I just don't
like when people place the line on
themselves
what do you mean like this is acceptable
what I do anymore is unacceptable what
do you well that's because I think is
boundaries for yourself you mean where
you go I can't do anything it's okay to
say for yourself okay for other people
like you shouldn't do anything more or
worse than what I do right because I am
what's right for everyone yeah well
there are there are objective truths to
drug use like like that's how they treat
addicts and junkies or by these
objective things that happen over time
to people that use frequently like so
there are objective realities that do
occur yeah I mean you can't you can't
say that that it's your problem that you
know that you how you are when you do
this drug all day and it's not my
problem you're just pushing your beliefs
on me that's that's true to a point but
it's also true that you're putting a
chemical in your body that you know yeah
but I'm like there's a lot of people who
would look at what the amount of pot
that you do and think you're wasting
your life you're an idiot you can't do
any harm to you know what's best for you
look I'm sure I'm sure that these people
have a point to the point that I'm
changing the way my brain is both that
was born have meaning you're not born
with weed in you right you know you're
you're changing your your thought
process you're changing your brain to -
I guess the default you're adding stuff
to it yeah so you can say that yes but
you can also say that about anything
like b12 vegetables
vitamins anything you can add to it
right so what I do is I don't try to
tell anyone what they should or
shouldn't girls like you know what
that's what I'm not telling you I'm just
saying that don't you find it odd that
you smoke all day long weed no you're
you're escaping your normal default
every day all day long well my high now
that you are probably forgot but even if
I did all day long I don't I don't see
it's anyone else's problem if you say
you're not going out you're not doing
comedy anymore then you're like there's
a valid yeah here's the thing I do think
that there are functional pot seems to
be the one exception to the rule because
pot doesn't really I don't know if it
really destroys your life the way other
drugs do and there are functioning pot
heads are people that for years get high
every day all day and have very
successful careers and a very successful
lives how the relationships are I don't
know cool kids are successful with it
yeah but coke has a lie a shorter
lifespan on and I think your body
ultimately can't sustain that amount of
really from one nostril to the other
nostril from doing coke but what's the
worst weed can do is what make you
fatter make you a bit dough beer yeah if
you were like look you snacks and
watching you're fat but I'm underweight
so it's like I'm not sure what the
problems are other at your short-term
memory yeah that's a reason not to smoke
pot ever smoked pot but I think it does
affect your relationships too because
you're not really connecting with people
you're yeah everything is beautiful now
I find everything way more interesting
and awesome are you in a relationship do
you have a girlfriend okay
well then yeah it doesn't matter but I
do know that personally in my experience
when I'm high I can't connect to other
people and I'm doing it because that's
so much to them really am I very since
I'm your sister and you didn't even know
what's going on I don't know how if
you're in a relationship that I could
have a serious conversation about you
about my period if you're fucking me but
you also like shiny objects you know you
know isolate to you it puts you in your
own
and it gets you into your own head
that's what it does for me I don't know
most the time I get highs at the economy
store with a bunch of people and we all
just super social your doctor's
appointments in 15 minutes oh he's got a
girl listen an hour so you just talked
about drugs yeah
well cool thanks for being here Ari and
taking the place of my husband no
problem any time maybe later tonight
fuck you Tom enjoy your fucking
blueberry muffin face where you guys at
where you at I'm at the funny farm in
Atlanta tomorrow and Saturday yeah it's
Friday and then Saturday Sunday I'm in
LA this weekend I'll be in San Francisco
for the sketch fest January 21st and
22nd or 22 21st at the purple onion all
right and red bander 90 show tonight if
anyone's around and thank you everybody
for listening to your mom's house and
it's your mom's podcast calm now it's up
there right now it's gonna be on iTunes
any day now iTunes I'm waiting for them
to approve it nice well cool until next
really on